prepare to meet the most terrifying
creatures
with four pairs of legs a tubular mouth
armed with stylets which can pierce its
prey and resilient
to all sorts of stressful conditions bit
of uv radiation
not a problem bone chilling cold
temperatures
also not a problem they can even survive
the vacuum of space
there's only one slight problem
tardigrades
are microscopic so hello and welcome to
the shaky science show
or should i say the spooky science show
as because
it is the beloved halloween special and
as evident from my intro we will be
talking about tardigrades in this video
otherwise known as water bears or moss
piglets
described by some as a cross between a
caterpillar
and naked mole rats well they're hardly
names that will fill you with fear
and i actually think they look quite
adorable especially when they're drawn
like this
so maybe this is the not so spooky
science show today
anyway it is kind of creepy or at least
the cool creepy
how they seem to be resilient to so many
things so
as a bit of fun i thought i would
elucidate some of these features an
underlying mechanisms of how we think
they work so far
also covering a recent study that seems
to pull apart how they can survive
uv irradiation and the reason why this
research is so fascinating is because we
can potentially learn from these
mechanisms
mimic them for therapeutics to help grow
plants on
extreme conditions and well to just
learn some really awesome biology
so to break this video down i'll begin
by just giving a generic
what are tardigrades overview and then
we'll look at what makes them special
covering a variety of different features
that have been noticed
so far and then going into a bit more
detail regarding this recent research
and their tolerance to ultraviolet
radiation
and then lastly we'll address why should
we actually care about the tardigrades
so first then what are tardigrades well
they're invertebrates belonging to the
phylum
tardigrada and currently it's estimated
that there are around
1 300 different tardigrade species
as you can see here they're closely
related to arthropods which include all
the crustaceans and insects
and also nematodes and the tardigrada
phylum itself can be split up into two
different classes
yuu tardigrada and heterotardigrada
yu tardikrada consists mainly of
freshwater and terrestrial species
whilst heterotardigrada include more
marine and terrestrial species
and the tardigrades can be found all
over earth from the deepest oceans
to the tops of the highest mountains and
although tardigrades are microscopic
they're surprisingly complex they have a
digestive
and nervous system albeit not as quite
complex as ours
and it also have sensory organs
including eyes
but if our digestive and nervous systems
are more complex than the tardigrades
what actually makes the tardigrade so
special well all tardigrades need
a thin water film around their bodies in
order to stay active
and whilst that might be fine for those
in marine or freshwater environments
those in terrestrial environments are
threatened by drying
however tardigrades have a special skill
tardigrades can enter into a state known
as the cryptobiotic states
and there are several different types of
this cryptobiosis
this includes an oxybiosis which is a
lack of oxygen
where tardigrades are known to swell and
become rigid
cryobiosis which is really low
temperatures
and osmobiosis which is changes in
pressure
and also anhydrobiosis which is due to a
lack of water
and so during these extreme conditions
cryptobiosis is induced
so cryptobiosis can be thought of as a
metabolic state
enters by an organism in response to
adverse environmental conditions
that prevents reproduction development
and repair
but enables the organism to survive so
that when the environmental conditions
return to normal
the organisms can return back to its
metabolic state of
life as it was before cryptobiosis
so anhydrobiosis gives the tardigrades
resistance to lack of water
and in addition it also helps the
tidigrades
deal with high temperatures radiation or
different kinds of chemicals such as
ethanol and carbon dioxide one
anatomical transformation
seen in some tardigrades during the
state is the formation of tan
which is when the tidy grades reduce
their body surface area
which helps to reduce water loss through
evaporation
and this is because water is super
important for organisms
in particular in cells water helps to
maintain the proper structure of
different proteins and different
macromolecular structures also including
dna
inevitably though the tardigrades are
going to lose some water
but they also have mechanisms to
circumvent this loss
firstly they can produce trahalus which
is a sugar compound
that can help to replace the lost water
and acts as a bioprotectant
but that isn't the only mechanism
tardigrades also produce
heat shock proteins that help to prevent
proteins from losing their structure
and aggregating together in addition
tardigrades have their own unique genes
that include the production of soluble
proteins that similarly
are thought to form molecular shields in
water deficient conditions
and interestingly a more recent
discovery of entire degrees
unique protein is that referred to as
dsop
standing for damage suppressor and it is
so named because it is thought that this
protein can bind to dna
and prevent it from damage and this
protein was first discovered in the
tardigrade species
are you ready for it ramos sotius
freonatus
apparently one of the most stress
tolerant tardigrade species
and what they found in this study was
that dsop could suppress
x-ray-induced dna damage by around 40
percent
and also suppress damage induced by
reactive oxygen species
and the coolest thing is that they also
put dsop and they expressed it
in human cells and even in the human
cells dsop was also shown to have
protective benefits for the dna
and it was in this follow-up paper where
they further characterized dsop
where they saw that it actually binds to
chromatin and they state as well in his
article
that with this insight dsop could be
used to expand the range of applications
of cells in biotechnology
and it could also increase the
effectiveness of current methods
such as the production of some
pharmaceuticals that depends upon the
use of cultured cells
so it's pretty cool that a protein from
tidy grades can have
relevance in other areas of research and
just while we're still on the topic of
dsop
it's interesting to think about why
tardigrades would need this protein
and so one argument would be that this
protein is made
as i just mentioned to protect dna but
the interesting thing about tardigrades
is that they're somatic cells so their
normal non-sex cells
are utalic so what that means is that
after hatching
those somatic cells don't divide so
maybe the integrity of their dna
isn't as important however in my opinion
dna is always important if you're going
to be transcribing genes
throughout a lifetime then it's integral
to also maintain the structure of dna
irrespective of whether or not that
cell's actually dividing
and this brings us on to the more recent
publication that was found in the
species of tardigrades
in the utah degrader class that found
that naturally occurring fluorescence of
this tardigrade's paramacrobiotis
protects the tidy grade from ultraviolet
radiation
and so this slightly takes us into the
realm of physics
and the energy of different waves with
ultraviolet light
having very high energy and so what was
seen in the study was that these
tardigrades
have the capability of transforming this
high-energy
ultraviolet light into harmless blue
light
and it is thought that only tardigrades
that have these fluorescent pigments
are able to do this and this can be seen
in this figure here
where you can see the tidy grade on the
left that is hypo pigmented
you can't see any of this blue light
under uv fluorescence
however the tidy grade on the right that
has got a lot more of these pigments
you can quite clearly see the blue light
under ultraphyllite fluorescence
pretty cool but the really neat thing
they did in this experiment
was extract these fluorescent pigments
and then coat
c elegans so these are worms in this
fluorescent pigments
and what they found was that the worms
had been coated in this fluorescent
extract
survived much better after uv radiation
exposure for 15 minutes
amolsis research is really exciting it
would be much more cool if we could
actually identify
what these fluorescent pigments are and
how it's encoded within the tardigrades
so that it can be used in different
applications and this is kind of a
reoccurring theme with a lot of the
adaptations of tidy grades to extreme
conditions
we can see what they're doing to
circumvent stress in these different
conditions
but we're not so sure about how they are
able to do this
and the biochemical underpinnings this
knowledge is really important for taking
the
cool biology from the tidy grades and
applying it to novel situations
this includes being able to improve
grave conditions
of different crops in extreme conditions
such as on mars
if that ever happens and it could also
help to protect workers from radiation
and nuclear facilities
as well as improving our understanding
of signaling mechanisms within cells
that could be useful for developing
therapeutics for cancer and aging
and the for rapid advances in genome
sequencing
will help to advance the research into
these thousands of species of
tardigrades
so i hope in this halloween special ish
i have treated you
not tricked you with some knowledge of
tardigrades
and as always thanks for listening